c'est non non
[Musique]
de très nombreux amateurs d'art nom
comprenant me demande s'il existe un
moyen discret de reconnaître au premier
coup d'oeil la joconde du choco certes à
première vue rien ne distingue la
joconde du choco alors réfléchissons
prends ta tête à demain mon cousin
comment en connaissons nous
habituellement un homme d'une femme
l'homme c'est celui qui va à la gare
ouais mais en temps de paix mais non en
temps de guerre comme en temps de paix
on reconnaît la joconde du jeu qu'on
exactement de la même façon qu'on
reconnaît un homme d'une femme à la
forme de son vélo etonnant non
[Musique]
etonnant non